So when I was,
I was having some pretty good thoughts on this acid and some different paths.
The killers,
by the way,
I fucking killed it.
Mm.
Um,
sob,
you see stuff in like when you're out there on psycho dog,
so a truth,
I call them universal truths where you just like,
yes,
that is real.
That is right.
100%.
And it's hard to bring that shit back into this realm,
you know,
to understand it.
It's trying to get us kicked off of Youtube.
It's passing car.
So it's hard when you come back to be like,
oh,
I saw the truth of something and then it's like,
and you can't express it.
And when people come back,
when they're around you,
they say something and you're like,
what?
And they're like,
they realized I get frustrated.
They're not saying it right.
And then it slowly going away.
So when I was there in that place,
sometimes I try to remember like when you get back,
say this to this person,
so that state told me to tell you that m and m is one of the real estate MCS.
I'm not going to argue with it.
I don't know what exactly it means,
but it was like,
does that could be a funny bit,
dude,
there's a funny bit in there like about how like some things are just in the
moment.
They seem so profound and then I'll be like,
what the fuck is wrong with me?
And my was one of the realest MCS.
Well I would agree with that.
I would say he's very,
very real.
It seems fairly real.
Yeah.
And as I heard it,
I was like,
that's going to sound dumb in the real world.
But I was like,
all right,
bet music awards thing he did where he will like freestyle,
right?
Well No,
some people liked it,
some people liked it.
The anti Trump thing,
everybody gets old artists get old.
But he was,
you know,
he was angry and he had all of his friends around him.
Yeah.
That was the weird thing.
Like why all those dudes just standing around kissing up?
No,
those,
they're all just hanging around these cars like in a circle.
They're all waiting while m and m wraps.
So he's got like all these,
it's the rap cypher.
That's what they all take turns.
Oh really?
They all did it turn you.
But where's the other ones?
The videos.
The other guys too.
I was like,
Oh,
mine was far better.
One guy steps forward.
I need to understand rap culture better.
I definitely almost said rape culture,
you know,
they go hand in hand to be Iti award shows.
That's how they do it.
They did at the bet awards show.
It's like a thing where they find it.
I'll fucking parking lot and go do it.
That different groups have different labels maybe would have taken to put up
their own guys.
It's called keeping it street.
Oh really?
That's interesting actually are not street.
You don't know anything.
That's why they had to tell you that.
I'm sorry.
And was one of the real estate MCS.
I already knew.
He keeps it street.
But uh,
that thing was,
it was interesting.
It's like when people,
you know,
when you create this big explosion,
this attack on someone from some that that's always fascinating to me to watch
that go down.
Like,
what's someone doing here?
Like what?
What's happening here?
What's,
what are you,
what is your support?
What was your take on it?
It wasn't as best work.
Right,
right.
You know,
I mean,
I think he's an amazing rapper.
Like some of his shit from the past is fucking incredible freestyle.
Well,
first of all,
I'm not feeling that cold chain.
Jamie's like,
but that was doing styles anymore.
It's not nothing to really freestyle.
It's just not,
I don't even hear it was freestyle.
Things are east.
I feel like you write up a lot of those.
Oh yeah.
It's all good.
Again,
it's all practiced.
Matt.
I liked the Cadillac in the back.
I'll tell you that.
I've got a boner for that lack on the right.
Yeah.
That looks like,
what is that like a 70 something Cadillac that things fucking beautiful.
Oh,
I love those things.
I don't give a fuck about this wrap with that.
Cadillac is the shit.
I got a boner for old cars,
dude.
I'm one of those old dudes that likes old music and old cars.
Do you see that?
That rap where it's like a,
I forgot who it was,
but it was like sang from the white point of view about what performance black
people,
and then from the black point of view,
as far as with white people,
that's a video is somebody like lips.
I can pretty well,
it's,
I'm like redneck Dude,
sorry.
Black people always complained about this and this,
and then it goes back.
Hmm.
I forgot who it is.
Young something.
But the problem with black people and white people is that people say black
people and white people.
I said just people.
Yeah.
Instead of just people.